[Music]
the Cape of Good Hope on the tip of
South Africa home to some of the most
treacherous waters on earth the currents
are unpredictable and the temperatures
are shockingly cold but for one man
these appalling conditions are just
perfect
you got then check over there Indian
over there you got the southern down
there your three oceans meeting here
say to storm here when you get in the
water
it is extremely unfriendly
endurance athlete Lewis Pugh swims in
the world's most dangerous waters in
order to highlight the severe threats
facing our oceans
now he's attempting something
unprecedented in the history of
endurance swimming he's going to risk
his life of England's southern shores in
the most dangerous swim of his career
we are completely redefining the eros of
swimming
[Music]
this is a very very best place which I
can train because it's some damn rough
which was swirling underneath you it's
it's scary and courage is a little bit
like a muscle you need to be swimming in
these conditions this is the best
training Lewis is in the final stages of
his preparation for the biggest
challenge of his life
I think the cumulative effect of day
after day after day in the cold water
the English Channel will make this
without a shadow of a doubt the toughest
sumup ever done I just don't know how
I'll do it
Lewis Pugh lives to swim and his
achievements are astounding as some in
the Arctic of some in icy waters of
Antarctica are some in some of the most
dangerous waters on this earth and the
coldest waters I rank this 10 out of 10
for deputy I think this is the most
difficult to swim I've ever undertaken
by a long way
I have seen our oceans change and we
need a wake-up call we need to really
take our ocean seriously and we need to
be protecting them
[Music]
what I've been seeing is the impacts of
climate change overfishing and pollution
I've seen how these swims can actually
change things with the long swim he's
campaigning to fully protect 30% of our
oceans by 2030
so about a thousand eight hundred people
have some across the English Channel
so from Dover to Calais or from Calais
to Dover what I'm planning to do is to
swim the full length of the English
Channel so starting in Lands End and
swimming all the way along the coasts of
South of England all the way to the end
to Dover it's five hundred and sixty
kilometres and I think it's going to
take me round about fifty days to
complete it's a it's a mammoth swim
[Music]
these are the clear blue waters
surrounding the Isle of Lundy twelve
miles off the coast of North Devon
it is Britain's first marine
conservation zone and it teams with sub
aquatic life
it is Louis's dream to introduce
protected areas like this around the
whole coast and it's one of the goals of
the long swim
it's a special place that's a very very
special place the first no takes out in
the United Kingdom this area is
protected shortly after I was born right
and now we've seen the benefits you're
not going to see short-term benefits
when you're creating big marine
protected areas it takes time and when
the benefits come they really do come as
wonderful just to swim here and to see
the puffins and the Guillemots and the
jellyfish and the seals and all these
animals living as they should
but when I came around the corner I saw
two and I popped up my head and I saw
these two told seals looking at me and
Ana Cairo sir I didn't realize they were
behind me it's humbling if you look at
them and you're in their world and it's
in this a beautiful world
the waters around the United Kingdom are
750,000 square kilometres of which only
seven square kilometres is properly
protected this is a gold standard Marine
Reserve the problem with it is it is
just so small we now need to create a
whole series of these around the United
Kingdom in the most important in the
most biodiverse areas to properly
protect the waters around the UK
it's an iconic swim the English Channel
about a thousand eight hundred people
are some across it I'm trying to bring a
message back to the United Kingdom I've
been away now for 30 years swimming in
the world's oceans and have really seen
them change dramatically if we are to
protect these waters we now need to take
serious action
now all the grueling weeks of lewis's
training are about to be put to the test
[Music]
over the next 50 days he will battle
through treacherous currents and chilly
waters wearing nothing more than
swimming trunks goggles and a bathing
cap
[Music]
put my head down and it's blue every
single shade of blue I put my head up in
these nice days everything I look up
this blue side the whole world is turned
blue I will be for 50 days it's a good
like a washing machine underneath me
better around the plate to be parts
names and which is a great start a long
way to go
[Music]
Lewis has succeeded in rounding Lands
End it's taken two hours of intense
effort and now it's time to rest
[Music]
to scored out there was fourteen point
three degrees we've been swimming in in
tougher conditions than this
but I thought it was gonna be good karma
today we're around land Zed and that was
the main thing for today to get around
lads it
[Music]
we've got eight of these charts between
here lands and all the way to Dover the
eight of them and all we've covered is
about seven kilometers so bloomin long
swim this for the next fifty days the
moon is my boss the tides are determined
by the moon our relationship the Earth's
relationship with the moon and if you
don't get it right you'll be going
backwards I'll be going back towards
Lands End it's been a good first day for
Lewis he's completed his objective of
rounding Lands End and morale is high
but not every day is going to be as easy
as the first because the channel holds
many hidden dangers
[Applause]
[Music]
it's 72 hours into Lewis pews attempt to
swim the length of the English Channel
and he's making good progress throughout
the challenge Lewis's followed at all
times by his support vessel the Aqualab
when Lewis finishes a swim his location
is marked by GPS we now log that when he
gets out the water and tomorrow morning
when he gets back in we'll put him in an
exactly the same position once again the
skipper is Steven Praetorius who charts
the daily swim and keeps a constant eye
on Lewis's well-being also onboard is a
cook a physiotherapist and a press
officer charged with making sure that
the expedition's environmental message
hits a wide audience although right now
he has a more immediate task
[Music]
on the jellyfish spot at the moment and
we're looking for these big yellow long
tentacle things and when I see one on a
direct reject fee with him on a blow
this whistle very very very hard because
it's difficult to get his attention
there's no way around it there is so
many jellyfish along this coastline and
they're gonna be days when I'm gonna be
very badly stung I put my hand on that
jellyfish and then accidentally scooped
it into my into my groin the toxic
jellyfish posed the biggest threat to
Lois during the long swim and he's in no
doubt as to why there are so many it's a
function of climate change waters are
getting warmer because they're getting
warmer we're getting more and more
jellyfish it's not fun being a swimmer
when they look when there's loads of
jellyfish around
[Music]
we're off to the lizard nearest is gonna
jump in the water
six o'clock it's gonna be quite exciting
generally he's going to go he's gonna
get swept out to sea or he's gonna get
swept into the rocks
[Music]
you can see a wall pulled over there you
see one there big ones of it yeah so
this current is moving very very quickly
[Music]
[Applause]
luis always knew this stretch was going
to be tricky but he's unprepared for
just how much danger he is in never be
in such a fast car to my life and it's
quite extraordinary
[Applause]
on board they're concerned about how
much longer they should allow Luis to
keep swimming
[Music]
the cute guy for another 10 minutes I
think we will put him on Felucia we all
arrival to the place
[Music]
Luis is determined to keep to schedule
but the crew are worried about the
energy sucking effect of the current
[Music]
Louis yeah damn outside yeah yep well so
it was like a river
it was just swirling underneath me
successfully shot the lizard loose
generally don't like killing lizards
this one we did it's a big milestone
because we finished the first Bay no
ants Bay next one actually doesn't have
a name it's just in front of Plymouth
and then the very very big one which is
live Bay
[Applause]
but it's a it's a big milestone in the
back while Lewis rests the crew
encounters a timely reminder of one of
the biggest threats facing the seas
ocean one plastics zero after a few
hours sleep Lewis is back in the water
Stephen has made a decision to change
course to try to catch up on the time
lost fighting the lizard current is it
the right one so we came in shore this
afternoon hoping to pick up a little bit
of a northeast Lee flowing shore after
we rounded lizard and as it turns out it
hasn't materialized so yeah swings and
roundabouts have done well up to this
point but today feels like a little kick
in the teeth to be honest
Lewis is down there swimming his hearts
out I'm trying to help him and when it
doesn't go your way you feel pretty bad
than what is cold today as well and lots
of jellyfish so we try and make it as
easy as possible for EM and when it
doesn't work out it's stuff
[Music]
one hour 20 Cabot pre-k and yesterday we
were coming 6 days in that time
apologize meant that
full control
[Applause]
frustrating I really
[Music]
I mean I hadn't see for so long we've
run out of water so we're now using our
final
just to wash off because real off to see
Prince Charles I guess he doesn't want
me to smell like fish and chips in
Cornwall the pressure groups surfers
against sewage have organized an oceans
plastic solutions day and they've
invited along a very special guest
I've been swimming in the world's oceans
and they're changing and I think
influences like the royal family hates
of business these type of people are
very very important in India guiding
public opinion
Lewis is delighted to have caught the
attention of royalty for the campaign
but time spent on Shore means that once
again he has a lot of catching up to do
[Music]
and then back to harbor to a ball away
to the north of the counties to meet the
Prince of Wales to talk about what we're
doing here and now require behind
schedule it's just early nighttime now
go get a soup into the night to make up
the time there's no letting up it's like
playing cricket if you get behind the
run right you've finished
[Music]
it's three days since Lewis went ashore
and the strain of having to keep to
schedule has taken its toll
what are you making lemon and ginger tea
is not feeling too well today and
hopefully this will cleanse a system he
is feeling exhausted physically and
mentally start thinking is sick he
stopped changing you start believing is
sick softly sorry for yourself don't
just carry on some are ready yeah
[Music]
but no matter how bad his feeling Louis
battles on hour after hour ultimately
there's only so much he can give every
single meter at the end there is a slug
yeah and I'm literally squeezed it's
like squeezing out that last tiny little
bit of juice place I'll achieve those
absolutely nothing left in me and I was
just holding on at the end
[Music]
by now the Aquila is settled into a
well-rehearsed routine but today they
have some visitors good wearing swimming
caps Christian is like you've had a mini
ice pick
[Music]
self-styled mad swimmin jockey Covell
holds the record for taking the longest
time to swim across the channel so what
better person to offer lewis moral
support
smashing
[Music]
this is a wake up with cleaner oceans
you know with the plastic which people
like Lewis do there are educate sailors
will gain that message across three
chairs the Lewis next stop a place very
close to Louis's heart there with is
Britain's ocean city it's a place of
excellence for all things maritime and
also people of Plymouth now are
campaigning for first marine National
Park here infamous sound to protect this
area for future generations
it's arrived in Plymouth is super
special because this is where I grew up
as a young boy and this is where I had
my first swimming lesson as part of
their campaign for a marine National
Park the swimmers have gathered for a
show of solidarity for the long swim
anyway
[Music]
[Applause]
you
the moment we looking at about 25 to 30
knots mm-hmm until 12 o'clock
I think we should get our asses out
there you know you got a long way to
swim it's on the edge of our alliance
for that wind speed 25 to 30 knots
maximum 30 knots I think we should just
[Music]
with winds at sea approaching gale force
Lewis is facing the most challenging
conditions of the swim to date everyday
is assuming day
this is
number one can you safely get me out the
wards again the to three safety
connector sports
even in these high seas Lewis is
determined to power on but Stephen is
nervous about the length of time he's
spending in these energy sucking
conditions
[Music]
it's easy to get off the boat so you
need to get back on the bus especially
in these conditions
Louis is exhausted he's just over a
third of the way through the swim but
already the strain is beginning to show
somebody just corkscrews like this
that's miserable at some 450 minutes
covered for kilometres is good but the
longer you're in there the more tired
you're getting the more Tiger getting
the more chances are not being able to
recover
[Music]
luis is now off the Dorset coast and
here he's joined by some fellow swimmers
who provide a much-needed boost to his
morale we were swimming along peacefully
they came along to say hello
today's swimming with a dolphin it's a
special day they come out of nowhere
assume underneath you
and darting backwards and forwards
they're playing with you they're looking
at you
but there's even more special wing when
you swim with them hear of English coast
busy just don't expect them here
this is why I'm doing this swimmer you
know I'm campaigning for the protection
of dolphins and whales and turtles and
sharks all the magnificent animals that
we have in our seas now these animals
that don't have a voice of Parliament's
requires people to stand up and speak on
behalf of them and to say we need large
fully protected marine protected areas
where these animals come and live in
peace and can start in juvenile in their
numbers to what they used to be many
many years ago after nearly four weeks
of hard slog a cause for celebration
lewis is now at the halfway point of the
long swim but away from the cheers a
serious problems developing lewis has
been battling hard to stay on schedule
but the strain he's placed on his body
now threatens the success of the entire
swim today
to see if I still feel I focus call of
pain
[Music]
the only thing that's real
with a incredible pain just right here
in my bicep and this started maybe 10
days ago and every day is just getting a
little bit worse
verse another's a big bump inside here
[Music]
be concerned because in the last couple
of days he seems to erase all and it
seems like it's not going away after
rais'd
and so we definitely need to get it seen
to and basically we just need to try and
maintain the area and get him through
the rest of the swim
they need the stains of time the
feelings
disappear
[Music]
after three more days of agony Lewis is
finally forced to come ashore
AFC Bournemouth is part of the local
community and the people who come here
or live on the coast and they're seeing
what's happening on the coast and they
care about it
[Music]
yes let's look at you let's examine you
and then see what we can do in it in
terms of helping you with your treatment
is very very humbling there's a little
groove in here in fact V that pretend
there's your bicep tendon runs through
this is your bicep tendon here you've
got a little bit of irritation around
the sheath of the tin and you see that
little bit of fluid sitting there now
that tendon of yours is what we call
reactive it's reacted to the load that
has got no surprise 25 days in the water
so it's a repetitive strain injury and
it's it's beginning to overload so it's
reacting to that load and that's what's
giving you a pain in the in the front
thing as you finish approaches it's
probably wise it doesn't give you advice
on that yeah isometrics can be really
helpful so static muscle contractions
your yeah you want to create tension
hold it 30 up to 30 seconds this list
will help you will give you pain relief
for about three hours so if you do this
before you get in look before you get in
the wood and you do it really well
it gives you an analgesic effect so it
actually stops that discomfort in the
tendon but there's no quick fixes
ideally you would say to people I'll
back off what you're doing and it'll
settle down it's fine we don't we don't
have that luxury now so the pain side we
dampen with those isometrics just
holding a spear like that it kills the
pain receptors really for about three
hours you don't feel anything well you
can do them what's three times a day
really Oh Nick this is something I step
in every day if you don't do it every
day it's going to get worse and you're
going to be in trouble in ten days time
it's the moments which challenges the
most which define us and
I'm sore and I'm injured and I've got a
long way to go and I'm not gonna stop I
just don't want to get such a
debilitating injury by the time I get to
the end of the console again
[Music]
a few hours after the treatment and
Lewis is back in the channel
[Music]
in spite of the rough seas he appears to
be coping well but after a grueling
session in the water disaster looms
the wind has picked up causing the
support vessel to accelerate away
leaving an exhausted Lois struggling to
keep up
my biggest nightmare that at the end of
a server absolutely exhausted and the
Seas going like this and then you can
slow it down and then up
gone
[Music]
another shipping forecast issued by the
Met Office on behalf of the maritime and
Coastguard Agency at oh five oh five
months with ten days left of the swim
Luis and Steven are now faced with a
familiar problem the weather temp Stover
white Southwest five or six occasionally
seven in Thames and over veering
northwest three or four later mainly
fair good so does 4/7 yeah yes
unsuitable
[Music]
but the pressure starts building up
because I've lost today sitting here
waiting
hour after hour after hour for the right
conditions is it's really frustrating
but I have to have that patience what 30
years of swimming has taught me is that
if you go into the English Channel at
the wrong time she'll spit you out
luis is stuck going nowhere and with no
sign of the weather clearing up there is
now a very real danger his dream of
swimming the length of the channel might
come to nothing I probably got another
10 days and my shoulder is getting more
and more painful and the weather is
getting worse and worse and I don't know
how long it's gonna last so I just I've
got to get through tonight's swim
at 1:00 a.m. the team heads out to see
it's the final leg of the long swim to
make up time lost to bad weather Louis
is going to have to swim at night it's
not a friendly place to be in the middle
of the channel in the middle of the
night is dark and I can normally see
them but they can't see me they can't
see what's happening in my eyes and
that's always a very important thing to
the skipper to see what's happening with
me at night or they can see as a little
glow stick on the back of me the
greatest danger is his own support boat
the catamaran weighs 10 tons it's easy
to get off a boat just dive off but much
more challenging at nighttime and
especially in the storm where the boat
is crashing up and down and I'm trying
to grab a ladder and it's dark and you
have a microsecond to make the right
decision to make the wrong decision even
knock yourself out or you can get
crushed underneath that boat it's high
stakes
you feel very disorientated so you can't
hear things you can't see things you're
on your own in the middle of the black
[Music]
[Applause]
we were blessed for the first must have
been three weeks we had absolutely
glamorous weather and just now the last
two weeks it's really become quite
challenging some big low pressures
whipping in off the Atlantic in one off
to the other and quite intense systems
moving very very quickly so we've
literally got a dive onto our swimming
windows when we get them as we have
placed the finishing line we've hardly
got any miles in the bag so it's it's
down to the wire at this point
Lewis finishes just after dawn and the
Gamble has paid off he has made up five
of the six miles needed to stay on track
every stroke I take his is getting me to
the final destination I just got to keep
on going irrespective of the weather
conditions now I think in total I'll
probably be doing well over half a
million strokes a lot of mileage I've
been dreaming about swimming past PG
head for well since I started because
this is really one of the most beautiful
places in England
there's the Seven Sisters and it's
special
[Music]
it's 5:00 a.m.
on day 43 and today we have for one big
strim because it looks like it's gonna
get a bit breezy this afternoon
the weather is becoming quite unsettled
by the dark ominous cloud looming
relentless bad weather is wreaking havoc
on the swim after six weeks the team is
drained of energy the adrenalin Lewis
had hoped were pushing through at the
end hasn't materialized
really tired average I'm getting about
three four hours sleep a night
and it will give you so much sleep
deprivation and when you have sleep
deprivation
[Music]
some today eight kilometers took me 2
hours 30 minutes it's like driving down
a motorway at 10 km/h it's been agony
[Music]
Lewis has one last headline to tackle
Dungeness this is proving to be the
toughest role of them it's almost as if
this one is saying yeah you think you
can get me in this trailer come past me
after a day in the water Lewis still
can't make it round the point is this
gets slower and slower and slower
everything your meter is a battle and I
just can't get around this headland so I
think it's better to to get out and come
back tomorrow will and I'm stronger
[Music]
to say we're the only people going on
today like definitely hundred percent
the seas are too rough for the catamaran
so the team hires a small boat to get
Lewis to his starting point and his
second attempt at rounding Dungeness
therefore cost girls our Waypoint is six
miles offshore from where we are now so
and run ontogeny so that's also going to
be
bigger Nastia
and Will's called it so we're gonna head
back very very very disappointed I saw
you guys
Ursula's
I'm showing you a minute don't worry I
said I wanted to go that's the way to go
hundred your safety your safety is my
responsibility
Johnson show you wanna go
my coding today was especially
disappointing today I had to get a swim
in to try get around Dungeness so we
could get to Dover on time now what we
faced was a situation where I have just
got three days now where I've got to
cover nearly 40 kilometres so now I'm
gonna be swimming day and night to get
to Dover on time
absolutely determined now somehow to get
around this point and once I'm around
this point then we're on the homestretch
but I'm lucky
[Music]
haha that's work Dungeness
finally we're done Jeunesse was in my
cabin last night in my bunk
the sinking is gonna be some cruel twist
of fate the being this channel wouldn't
let me finish this
[Music]
I know it's 30 kilometres to Dober it's
a straight run home on to the
[Music]
I've always knew that this son was going
to be incredibly tough but I hadn't
factored in was just hot tough it would
be at the end I'm mentally exhausted and
physically exhausted and emotionally
exhausted the team is exhausted we are
wor exhausted but also excited were so
excited we can see the white blessed
over the long swim has made the
government sit up and take notice
the UK's Environment Secretary is on
board for Lewis's final dive into
channel waters
[Music]
myself
good luck
come on
[Music]
I am NOT going to stop until we get the
our coastline properly protected at the
moment it isn't at the moment this place
is being overfished there's huge amounts
of pasture going into the oceans which
is having a very very serious impact on
the environment I won't stop until we
get this situation sorted out by it's a
bit tough there's a little bit colony
got I think another two kilometres nah
no so excited to finally get there I've
been dreaming of this day but nearly 50
days to finally see the White Cliffs of
Dover and over there is the end
[Applause]
[Music]
and in just 49 days he makes
this long swim is not about trying to
become the first person to supercooling
in his channel who was about trying to
deliver a message
do it it takes
[Music]
to
just away
[Music]
see
[Applause]
[Music]
you